I mean that is that's New York
uninvestable sorry don't shoot the
messenger just telling you the way it is
yes
some pushback from our our elected
officials in New York on that's going to
say Kathy hokels yeah but we'll debate
them any time of the day you want we
would love to discover
she's great at killing jobs she kills
jobs by that thousands you know another
New Jersey problem where did Amazon take
their jobs they took them away from her
she threatened to sue them if they
created jobs I mean this is a reality
this is a reality that there's a little
more to it but let's not really well
sorry just telling the truth he's saying
what a lot of people are saying
especially what happened with that
Amazon thing here in New York lemon
getting one right at the end there
absolutely incredible must have been
opposite day you can see the way the
other anchors look they want to act as
the litigators as the lawyers for the
Democrat policies right and of course
what he said what Mr Wonderful said was
I'll debate her I'll debate hoko I'll
debate AOC on this stuff any day